good morning look at the view out of
here looks like a scene from Europe
Isn't that cool look at that
we got the mountains in the back the
trees
got this steam coming from probably the
heater or something down there
if you were line it up I wonder there's
like a bus station
like a shuttle to get to the resorts
but man this place looks so peaceful
look at that
hey Mia you having a good time you
having a good time with us
what a good time oh
good girl
my good girl you're the best you're the
best dog ever
look how cool this town is so the
mountain is right there the beautiful
sunrise is coming up there's snow all
over the place and we found this super
bomb breakfast joint that's not to be
covered by this truck that is Driftwood
Cafe
has thousands of reviews of breakfast
looks really really good about to get
some breakfast before I do some super
fun stuff I'm not gonna say it out loud
because I do want to surprise him okay
I'll tell you guys we're gonna go tubing
so I found this thing called tube Tahoe
where you can get like a little an inner
tube and it's made just for that so
you're not you have to worry about
skiers or snowboarders or anything like
that and it's supposed to be really
smooth really fun and the tube is high
quality so no one gets hurt nothing's
gonna have a freaking blast
I cannot get over this view okay I'm
right in front of Driftwood Cafe and
look
this like little shot right here looks
like a screensaver
oh my goodness that is beautiful let me
change the camera settings
look at that
oh my goodness Mama I love breakfast
diners like this like super cozy CUNY
mom and pop ones do you like them
um I do because it's creamy my name so
today I think I'm gonna have a cheat
meal
places like this I feel like they got
Grandma's recipe you know what I'm
talking about you know the place got
Grandma's recipe I I I think I'm gonna
look at the mini first today to
determine that
sure look chicken fried steak what is
that Grandma's recipe
you got a double crayon damn Bloods and
Crips were together that's pretty cool
you're so bad over here what are you
talking about no I'm not yeah I'm from
L.A okay
can I get the chicken fried steak
uh sunny side up please it was kind of
potatoes would you like I got house
potatoes hash brown or mashed potato
pancakes house you always got to go at
the house
potatoes do you want to make them crispy
a little bit crispy yeah
whipped cream cheese and strawberries
and then it comes with two eggs
oh okay it's a combo I think he just
want what did you want mister only
strawberries and French shows that's it
yeah
it's a smaller portion of French toast I
think we need to do the adult what did
we need to do the adult version yeah
yeah yeah yeah we need the adult version
okay my turn all right
oh yeah
oh it almost tricked me I didn't almost
didn't see you put that Circle right
there
whoa oh someone's using their Noggin huh
you gotta use a red side plan
Cottages okay all right that might be a
tight game
yes oh breakfast burrito okay
that's incredible
chicken fried foyer
oh look at that gravy and the house
potatoes thank you so much of course
oh are you happy boy this is full on
cheat meal now so I'm gonna take this
watch this egg put it right here pop the
yolk right on to this I'm glad they even
gave me a biscuit I never get biscuits
even though I love them because they're
the least nutritious thing in the whole
world but I got butter biscuit Jam but
look
get that yolk and that gravy Grandma's
recipe I don't even know this Grandma's
recipe of course you don't know but when
you're in Tahoe in a place like look at
that snow look at this beautiful
breakfast
environment you know what I mean like
how can I get something that's diet
work every bite you know what I'm saying
which one are we in California or
which one did you want which one did you
want oh that one's cool too I like that
one too don't forget your artwork we
gotta get a magnet for Grandma yeah we
have to okay monkey
are you ready
let's see if you could see it
this is the fun stuff I was talking
about what side are we looking now for
on the right uh left side that side yeah
I sure hope it's not it's not a doubt
but it's gonna be fun
and I know it's gonna be fun because
you're my son and you're a rascal like
me
oh I think I ended oh actually you can't
see it I thought you're gonna be able to
see it through
um on the street but you're not you have
to enter here first
okay
oh
do you see that he doesn't know what
that is see what those big old slopes
are
that looks closed for some reason
why does it look closed no okay
I hope it's not I really hope it's not
because those little Mountains will be
so fun with the we're gonna slide them
slide down with the tube
the snow tube
[Music]
it's a crybaby what I'm talking about
you cry baby this trip has been a bunch
of ups and downs and ups and downs like
oh it's gonna happen it's not gonna
happen but good thing they are open I
just talked to someone so yes so you get
to have fun and I think they just opened
because no one else is here meaning
yesterday was inclement weather just
like how Mammoth was so I think
everything was super close but that's
the slope right there
and there's literally no one on it which
is super freaking cool we get to have
the place to ourselves here Mister you
ready to have some fun yeah
we go
wow look at all the snow out here it's
so cool that this is just a tubing park
and look how much snow there is
this is crazy
whoa look it back there oh my goodness
that is insane
okay let's go let's go hoodies
what time would you like what color do
you want Mr
um
can he go on the the kids room by
himself right here absolutely so you
guys can have um you can do that
definitely by himself okay oh and it's
just right here and it's actually
running really fast today so um I'm not
gonna let he won't be able to go on his
own at the top okay just yet unless it
starts slowing down but yeah he needs a
ride with you okay
time to get inside are you ready
are you holding holding on tight look at
this put your hand in his handles still
see and the other one yep
all right you ready
okay there
grab it okay you ready
oh my God are you serious okay here we
go ready
okay one
two
three whoa
oh we missed it oh he missed it
we missed the bowling pins
hey who's that
who's that over there
it's mama
of course he misses the bowling pins and
he has to go run and jump inside
you crazy guy
okay let's try it again
all right so Dad and Tech are gonna go
right now
I need some glasses
I think they're up at the hill now watch
them
[Music]
but of course setting up his camera
here we go
here they go
[Music]
that was fast
that
I think that was faster than
snowboarding
maybe the way you snowboard was that
good
hey why are you making fun of me well
that was crazy bones
here they come
oh my God it is powerlifting
gpp right here sled drags real sled
drags
okay you ready sucker
yeah
ready to go sucker
okay ready losers yep three two one
foreign
all right we're taking one last good
look at the beautiful Lake Tahoe before
we head out to Sacramento and this place
is gorgeous
it is massive
it's beautiful but it's not the entrance
you know yeah that entrance that first
shot from yesterday that was gorgeous
I kind of want to jump in that water
babe
it could be down
Down for What
down to let me
you're stupid yeah
should I should I try it no take off my
clothes right here and then jump in
right now if you run from here
I gotta touch the water with my hands at
least okay let's go
okay we're at the very edge of the lake
if your feet get wet they're gonna be so
cold dude
because look at our biggest happy faces
his face is so happy you see how big his
happy face is
no it's pretty cool you're gonna touch
it yeah just touch this a little bit
look at her it's not as cold as I
thought though
I thought it would be really cold
that's not that cold
what the are you talking about it's
literally I really ice water is it yeah
it is cool but not that cold so give me
a Mia
monkey
we're all changed ready to go where to
Sacramento but first what are we doing
what do you want to put on tell me first
I can clean it right there okay that's
where the Tahoe One's Gonna Go
oh my god did you just
huh
oh his breath I thought he looked it
right here okay
press it rub it rub it
nice okay okay okay one more
it's okay what do you want this one to
go
right here that's a good spot
is this a beautiful memory or what
okay there you go you hold the right
side I hold this side okay how cute does
this look
nice and tight we kind of messed up with
this one miss Mammoth one it's not as
close as the other ones but it's kind of
cool it has a year
as a year and it has a big elephant like
the picture he took
hey that's looking really cool
that would be a Sacramento one and then
a San Francisco one another
Mama's hooking up some Gourmet
Sandwiches they're not Gourmet yeah they
are on the side of the road
these things came in handy because we're
on our way from Tahoe to SAC and we
didn't see anything pop up but we have
to stick to schedule we got to get taika
fed and in bed by like 2 30 ish so he
could nap and then we can arrive at
Sacramento so he feels nice and good
this cooler does look freaking awesome
now look at they're both peeing okay
and everything together that's cute and
uh I got my ground beef that came in
handy see it's always helpful to have
these in-between meal things
this meal is actually pretty helpful
because I ate horrendously for breakfast
as you guys saw just straight off the
rails so the fact that I have zero carbs
and almost zero fat all protein is gonna
help out a lot yeah it doesn't look like
you want to eat it that looks like Mia's
food I know but hey I've been I've been
getting sexy
you gotta do what I gotta do I'll give
you that why is that red right there red
oh I was just a reflection of the light
you see
okay it seems like there's a new
tradition the new tradition is every
hotel we go in we have to see if it gets
taika's approval
there used to be all of this stuff in
here so you like the way this bridge is
organized yeah
what do you think about this hotel do
you approve
okay all right monkey are you ready for
the interview are you ready okay we
gotta start from it we gotta start from
the outside okay
we're gonna start from here you gotta
start from over there go go
and the tradition is Mia has to pee on
the car no don't be oh my gosh she's
already looking I just walked here I
know we did I walked through
wait look at us
and then my car but I think that's her
like little security blanket meal
therapy I just walked you okay so Tycoon
so what do you think
the last three of them okay what's
better is it bigger does it smell better
what is it is it the beds no okay yeah
open it what do you think what do you
think yeah
ew there's a toilet in there
oh sorry I can't put a toilet in here
you know what else
you were so impressed yeah because I
always see lines and then and then the
bottom is Wags but this one's changes
yeah that was different that one is
different then what's that I thought
that was a refrigerator no no that was a
cool that was a freezer that's a freezer
okay all right okay do you know what bed
you're gonna pick
who knows
like a crew like a crew box true boss
you can play a player is that better
see I told you it's cool
you don't talk to Mom like that duh
that's it there you have it okay wait
one out of three one it's a really bad
Hotel three it's so good what number do
you give it one two or three what number
one you don't like it you just said it
was the best one
actually Infinity we just learned that
on the trip cool the bathroom actually
has a really cool picture of historic
Sacramento check this out
look at that many of you guys may not
know this but Sacramento is actually one
of my favorite cities in California
because it kind of reminds me of like
the east coast of California like
there's so much history here there's so
many buildings are that are um
historical versus most of LA and SoCal
everything is technically brand new
everything's built within like the last
80 years
no one's been around or no houses have
been over 200 years and stuff like that
so that's why I really like Sacramento
has this very historic Vibe which is
super cool but at the same time it's
super suburby and by the time
um
work gets out like around five the whole
city dies out and it's chill because you
guys know me I like it when it's super
duper chill and what do you do hmm
are you trying to smell the pee did she
pee no she just smiling around like a
good dog look a good doggo
she's been the best travel buddy ever
Mia
you know even the best travel buddy ever
have they actually grew on this trip to
be honest
Mike
uh
dude she's like the fans Snow Dogs she's
the best what's up loser hi Mia
hi sweetheart hi sweetheart what's wrong
with your voice he got all of us sick
yeah we're all sick
she's got Tahoe water on it yeah hey
babe check it out this is the worst tour
guide in the world okay what's the name
of this bridge Mike
this bridge that's painted yellow so
everyone could see I do know it's from
like 1930s right what's the name of the
bridge though it's so yellow the tower
bridge is it yup okay wow yep just give
me a second the tower bridge I remember
being a kid yeah and they vote
you high taika up yeah and he was look
at you like look at this bridge and then
we went towards you and we didn't drive
on it oh that's you crushed his dreams
bro taking him to the candy store
who's gonna pay uh definitely Gio
Mia yeah the big monies
okay Mike what's the significance of Old
Sac I don't really know but I do know
this was like one of the first place
they settled I don't know if it was
Lewis or Clark or who are the people
that ate themselves the Donner Party the
Donner Party yeah the Donner Parties by
Tahoe okay and they ate each other and
then half of them made it and then they
settled here that's what that's the
history of Sacramento why is it the
capital there I think because of that
joking aside I do think we were one of
the first places they settled so like
moving West and why is it so like old
school so I think it's because so this
is called Old Sac yeah which obviously
isn't that great of a name if you think
about it's kind of weird I like the way
it looks like but it does and so it's
very like Western I think these
Cobblestone yeah I think all these
cobblestones are real and then oh wow
now it's just kind of touristy though
yeah so there's like food and you'll see
like this candy store is kind of cool
but there's a comedy place a couple bars
and it's on the river so that's why I
think they all stopped here yeah that
bridge is like our main river the
Sacramento river that comes from Tahoe
that water oh that's it yeah oh cool
yeah and then uh we have shutter sport
John Sutter dude I actually do know
things he was the guy that settled you
just know names you don't know the
stories I think was the first one to
settle here because there's a huge Force
what is he known for I think settling in
Sac I think he I think he's I think he's
known for settling I think he's shoved
that flag you ever seen that he said
this is for America
but what's your name what are you known
for I settled
settler not like I said lowering the bar
but usually what's it called settling
colonizing
all right so we're at this part of town
we still gotta get a sticker and a
magnet hey monkey you gotta keep her
eyes peeled for a Sacramento sticker
okay mister that's over here
[Music]
Bingo okay see if they got names on
license plates that's exactly what we're
looking for okay okay I see postcards
postcards what is that California shoe
monkey
okay here's some stickers
be kind
Sacramento oh this one is that one oh
that's pretty cool
that one is cool are you potion Mama
that is potions hey monkey you want that
one or you want that guy with the
backpack
which one which one do you want
of course
why you don't like that one
if you ain't clocking you're in rocket I
hate that how come they don't have a
simple like Capital One what's wrong
with these guys they're comfortable dude
what's up uh all the times I've been to
Sacramento or never gotten a shot of the
capital
so here it is
the capital of California
hey look you see the capital that's the
capital
of course you don't but just remember
that in your brain okay I don't know
what it means either dude it means where
they make the important decisions
yeah like like gun control decision
that's where they make all the important
gun control decisions okay
he's gonna shoot you in the back you
better be careful the capital's watching
I'm gonna press the button nope the cat
what button the trigger he said oh no no
no the captain's watching it
all right you guys saw the garbage I ate
for lunch we're having a peace for
dinner and I got a big squat tomorrow so
you know what I gotta go to for a big
spot Pizza paper baby got pizza we got
carbonara got spaghetti and meatballs
yeah short rib puppet
thank you so much thank you cheers I
like your uh spirit jersey friends okay
back in the room pretty wiped I've been
driving a lot these days
um it was really good connecting with
sound of the mic so we're gonna go to
sleep
because tomorrow morning I have to wake
up early and we got a long long day
tomorrow I got a train
and after I've got to get on the road to
hit SF and then get back in La so we can
spend uh Grandma's birthday with Grandma
so we'll see you guys tomorrow good
night say good night mister
shut up look at these glasses do you
someone like can let me keep them I know
you're so nice huh yeah I'm rich
um